Vítej zpět u seriálu Porozumění kvantové informaci a výpočtům. Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický
ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM Quantum. Toto je 11. lekce seriálu a třetí lekce ve
třetím bloku, který pojednává o obecné formulaci kvantové informace. Tato lekce je o měřeních, která představují
rozhraní mezi kvantovou a klasickou informací. Když je provedeno měření na systému, který se nachází v
kvantovém stavu, je extrahována klasická informace, která odhaluje něco o tomto kvantovém stavu a obecně ho mění nebo
ničí. Ve zjednodušené formulaci kvantové informace, která byla probrána
v prvním bloku seriálu, obvykle omezujeme svou pozornost na projektivní měření, včetně
nejjednoduššího typu – měření ve standardní bázi. Je však možné zobecnit pojem měření,
a to se ukáže být docela užitečné. V této lekci budeme mluvit o měřeních v plné obecnosti –
včetně toho, jak jsou popsána matematicky a jak zapadají do obecné formulace kvantové
informace. Ke konci lekce se také podíváme na několik základních pojmů spojených s měřeními – konkrétně na diskriminaci kvantových stavů
a kvantovou tomografii stavů. Tak pojďme na to. Zde je přehled
lekce. Jak to běžně děláme, začneme základy, včetně dvou různých, ale ekvivalentních způsobů, jak
popsat měření matematicky. Konkrétně měření můžeme popsat jako kolekcemi matic
a také jako kanály, na které jsem narážel v předchozí lekci. Probereme také parciální
měření – jinými slovy měření prováděná jen na části většího složeného
systému. Poté přejdeme k Neimarkovu teorému, což je základní fakt o měřeních, který v podstatě
říká, že obecná měření lze vždy implementovat jednoduchým způsobem připomínajícím Stinespringsovu
reprezentaci kanálů. Stručně řečeno, obecná měření lze vždy implementovat tak, že nejdříve zavedeme
inicializovaný pomocný systém, poté provedeme unitární operaci a nakonec provedeme měření standardní báze
na pomocném systému. Ukáže se, že to je poměrně snadné dokázat, a podíváme se, jak to funguje. Uvidíme také, jak se to
váže k tzv. nedestruktivním měřením, která popíšu. Nakonec v poslední části
lekce probereme diskriminaci kvantových stavů a kvantovou tomografii stavů. Začneme matematickými
popisy měření. Měření nám poskytují rozhraní mezi kvantovou a
klasickou informací – když je provedeno měření na systému, který se nachází v nějakém kvantovém stavu, je extrahována klasická informace
o tomto kvantovém stavu. Kvantový stav je navíc obecně změněn nebo případně
zcela zničen. Zpočátku soustředíme svou pozornost na tzv. destruktivní měření, kde
kvantový stav vstupuje a na výstupu je pouze klasická informace – bez specifikace
postmeasurementového kvantového stavu měřeného systému. Intuitivně si můžeme představit, že destruktivní měření
zničí měřený systém, takže jeho stav po měření není
specifikován. To doslova neznamená, že fyzická zařízení jsou nutně zničena – je to jen matematický
popis, ale velmi užitečný, protože pomáhá zjednodušit věci a soustředit se na podstatné
matematické aspekty měření. Existují zejména dva ekvivalentní způsoby, jak popsat destruktivní
měření, o kterých jsem se zmínil v přehledu lekce. Jeden způsob popisu destruktivního
měření je pomocí kolekce matic, kde máme konkrétně jednu matici pro každý možný výsledek
měření. Druhý způsob popisu destruktivního měření je pomocí kanálu, kde
vstupem je stav měřeného systému a výstupem je vždy diagonální matice hustoty, kterou můžeme
interpretovat jako popis rozložení pravděpodobnosti přes možné klasické výsledky
měření. Oba popisy jsou ekvivalentní, a to je docela užitečné, protože nám to umožňuje vybrat si ten pohodlnější
v dané situaci. Budeme také mluvit o nedestruktivních měřeních, kde je vedle klasického výsledku
měření specifikován i postmeasurementový kvantový stav měřeného systému.
Nedestruktivní měření jsou důležitá a vyskytují se často, ale v určitém smyslu
nejsou tak fundamentální jako destruktivní měření – z matematického hlediska. Konkrétně se ukáže,
že nedestruktivní měření lze vždy popsat jako složení kanálů a destruktivních měření,
a jak to funguje, uvidíme o kousek dál v lekci. Nyní se podívejme na to, jak měření – tedy destruktivní
měření – lze popsat jako kolekce matic. V průběhu tohoto výkladu budeme předpokládat, že X je systém, který se
měří. Pro jednoduchost uděláme pár předpokladů. Za prvé budeme předpokládat, že
klasická stavová množina X sestává z celých čísel od 0 do n minus jedna pro nějaké kladné celé číslo n, a možné
výsledky měření jsou celá čísla od 0 do M minus jedna, opět pro nějaké kladné celé číslo M. Nemusí
existovat žádný vztah mezi n a M – obě jsou libovolná kladná celá čísla. Samozřejmě bychom mohli nahradit
tyto množiny libovolnými klasickými stavovými množinami, pokud bychom chtěli. Nejprve si připomeňme, jak fungují projektivní
měření, o nichž jsme poprvé mluvili ve třetí lekci seriálu. Za předpokladu, že výsledky měření jsou celá čísla od 0 do n minus jedna, popisujeme projektivní měření kolekcí
projekcí Pi 0 až Pi M minus jedna, jejichž součet je matice identity. Tyto matice mají řádky a
sloupce odpovídající klasickým stavům X – jinými slovy jde o matice n×n.
Pokud je X v kvantovém stavu popsaném vektorem kvantového stavu s, pak každý možný výsledek
měření a se objeví s pravděpodobností rovnou kvadrátu eukleidovské normy Pi a vynásobené
vektorem s. Kvadrát eukleidovské normy libovolného vektoru je roven skalárnímu součinu vektoru se sebou samým,
takže dostaneme výraz zobrazený na obrazovce. Ten lze trochu zjednodušit
tím, že Pi a je projekce – takže její aplikace na sebe samu nic nedělá –
a nakonec lze výraz přepsat mírně odlišným způsobem pomocí cyklické vlastnosti
stopy, jak je ukázáno na obrazovce.
Pokud ti není jasné, proč to chceme takto zapsat, krátká odpověď je, že chceme pochopit, jak projektivní měření fungují pro matice
hustoty. Konkrétně: díky linearitě, pokud je stav X popsán maticí hustoty ρ místo
vektoru kvantového stavu s, je pravděpodobnost výsledku a dána stopou projekce
Pi a krát matice hustoty ρ. To musí tak být, protože – jak jsme viděli –
matici hustoty lze vždy vnímat jako váženou sumu čistých stavů. A pokud zprůměrujeme
odpovídající pravděpodobnosti, dostaneme tento výraz, protože stopa je lineární funkce. To je tedy výraz, o který
nám jde, a trochu ho upravíme, abychom se soustředili na matice
hustoty. Hlavním cílem je mimochodem navázat na to, co jsme se už naučili,
a ukázat, že tento popis projektivních měření je ve skutečnosti speciálním případem obecnějšího popisu měření, na který se
teď podíváme. Proto nyní nahradím tento popis fungování projektivních měření pro matice hustoty
popisem pro obecná měření, abychom pochopili vztah. A tady je:
obecné měření – ne nutně projektivní – je popsáno kolekcí pozitivně semidefinitních
matic P 0 až PM minus jedna, jejichž součet je identita. Pokud je toto měření provedeno na X v
stavu popsaném maticí hustoty ρ, pak se každý výsledek a objeví s pravděpodobností rovnou stopě PA krát
ρ. Stručně řečeno: jedinou změnou je, že jsme uvolnili podmínku na tyto matice – konkrétně matice
nemusí být projekce, stačí, aby byly pozitivně semidefinitní. Odpovídajícím způsobem jsem nahradil písmeno Pi písmenem P,
protože Pi je konvenční označení projekce, zatímco P rád používám pro pozitivně semidefinitní
matice. Jde o zobecnění předchozího popisu projektivních měření – protože projekce jsou vždy pozitivně
semidefinitní. Ve skutečnosti je lze alternativně definovat jako pozitivně semidefinitní matice, jejichž vlastní hodnoty
mohou být pouze nula nebo jedna. Vidíme, že tato definice
dává smysl v tom smyslu, že pro pravděpodobnosti výsledků vždy dostaneme vektor pravděpodobností, a to následovně:
Za prvé, tato čísla, která nazývám pravděpodobnostmi výsledků, jsou vždy nezáporná reálná čísla, protože
PA i ρ jsou pozitivně semidefinitní a stopa součinu dvou pozitivně semidefinitních
matic je vždy nezáporné reálné číslo – proč tomu tak je, nechám na tobě k zamyšlení.
Za druhé, tato čísla musí dát součet jedna, protože stopa je lineární, matice P 0 až PN minus jedna mají součet rovný identitě
a matice hustoty mají stopu rovnu jedné. Bez ohledu na to, kterou matici hustoty ρ zvolíme, pravděpodobnosti výsledků tedy vždy tvoří
vektor pravděpodobností. Podívejme se teď na několik příkladů. Už jsem zmínil, že
projektivní měření jsou speciálním případem obecných měření, protože projekce jsou vždy pozitivně semidefinitní.
Začněme ale jednoduše: projektivní měřením qubitu ve standardní bázi. Měření standardní báze qubitu
lze reprezentovat dvěma maticemi P 0 a P1, definovanými tak, jak je vidět na obrazovce. P 0 je |0⟩⟨0| a P1 je |1⟩⟨1|.
Obě jsou pozitivně semidefinitní matice – a ve skutečnosti jsou to projekce – a zjevně jejich součet je
identita. Dohromady tedy popisují měření. Pokud toto měření aplikujeme na qubit
v stavu popsaném maticí hustoty ρ, pak pravděpodobnost výsledku nula je stopa P 0 krát ρ
a pravděpodobnost výsledku jedna je stopa P1 krát ρ. Díky cyklické vlastnosti stopy dostaneme
dvě diagonální položky ρ, jak očekáváme. Zde je další příklad, kde tentokrát matice nejsou projekce –
jsou ale pozitivně semidefinitní a jsou to navíc matice hustoty, i když to není podstatné. Podstatné je,
že jejich součet je identita, takže dohromady popisují měření. Můžeme vidět, co se stane, když toto měření provedeme na qubitu ve stavu plus, třeba
jen pro jeden příklad stavu – výpočet pravděpodobností je zobrazen na
obrazovce. Všimni si zejména, že ačkoli stav plus je čistý stav a můžeme ho reprezentovat vektorem kvantového stavu |+⟩, musíme do vzorců dosadit
reprezentaci tohoto stavu maticí hustoty, konkrétně |+⟩⟨+|, abychom získali
pravděpodobnosti. A dodám, že protože mluvíme o destruktivním měření, není tu žádná
specifikace postmeasurementového kvantového stavu tohoto qubitu – takže máme pouze specifikaci
pravděpodobností výsledků. Zde je poslední příklad pro tuto chvíli – docela zajímavý. Opět je to měření
jednoho qubitu. Začneme definováním čtyř vektorů kvantových stavů, které jsou tzv.
tetrahedrální stavy. Nazývají se tak, protože odpovídají čtyřem vrcholům
pravidelného čtyřstěnu vepsaného do Blochovy sféry. Abychom byli přesní – pravidelný čtyřstěn
je čtyřstěnné těleso, kde každá stěna je rovnostranný trojúhelník. Jde tedy o dokonalou symetrii –
každá hrana má stejnou délku a úhel mezi libovolnými dvěma sousedními
hranami je stejný. A nyní můžeme definovat zajímavé měření se čtyřmi možnými výsledky, jak je ukázáno na obrazovce – jinými slovy naše
matice jsou reprezentace těchto stavů maticemi hustoty vydělené dvěma. Tyto matice jsou
určitě pozitivně semidefinitní, protože jsou to matice hustoty vydělené dvěma. Aritmetiku bys mohl projít a ověřit,
že jejich součet je skutečně identita – ale jiný způsob, jak to vidět, je prostřednictvím symetrie. Pokud tyto čtyři stavy zprůměrujeme,
dostaneme zcela smíšený stav, který leží ve středu Blochovy sféry. Protože ale každý dělíme
dvěma místo čtyřmi, dostaneme dvojnásobek zcela smíšeného stavu – tedy identitu. O tomto měření teď víc říkat nebudu –
jen poznamenám, že nejde o projektivní měření, ale je to hezký příklad a
vrátíme se k němu v lekci. Jiný způsob popisu obecných měření je pomocí kanálů, jak si teď
ukážeme. Myšlenka spočívá v tom, že klasické pravděpodobnostní stavy lze reprezentovat diagonálními maticemi hustoty, takže
protože výsledky měření jsou klasické, můžeme o měřeních přemýšlet jako o kanálech, jejichž výstup je vždy diagonální matice hustoty.
Jiný způsob popisu obecných měření je pomocí kanálů, jak si teď ukážeme. Myšlenka spočívá v tom,
že klasické pravděpodobnostní stavy lze reprezentovat diagonálními maticemi hustoty, takže
protože výsledky měření jsou klasické, můžeme o měřeních přemýšlet jako o kanálech, jejichž výstup je vždy diagonální matice hustoty.
Popis výsledků měření jako matice hustoty, který popisuje výsledek měření – podívejme se na to trochu podrobněji. Pokud přemýšlíme
abstraktně o obecném měření, můžeme ho popsat jako kanál φ. Vstupní systém tohoto kanálu je
systém X, který se měří, a výstupní systém je systém Y, jehož klasické stavy odpovídají
výsledkům měření – tedy celým číslům od 0 do n minus jedna pro nějaké kladné celé číslo
M. Protože výsledky měření jsou klasické, požadujeme, aby pro každou vstupní matici hustoty ρ pro systém
X byl výstup φ(ρ) diagonální maticí hustoty. Například pokud uvažujeme o
měření qubitu ve standardní bázi a myslíme si na toto měření jako na kanál, lze ho vyjádřit takto.
Pokud je vstupní matice hustoty ρ, dostaneme výsledek nula s pravděpodobností rovnou ⟨0|ρ|0⟩
a výsledek jedna s pravděpodobností ⟨1|ρ|1⟩. Pokud tedy vyjádříme tyto klasické
výsledky měření jako matice hustoty, dostaneme tento výraz pro odpovídající kanál. A ukáže se,
že jde o kanál úplného dephazování. To je v souladu s myšlenkou, že kanál úplného dephazování
reprezentuje extrémní formu dekoherence – což může znamenat různé věci, ale když tento termín používám, mám
na mysli tendenci kvantových stavů stávat se klasickými, protože prostředí kolem systému, o kterém
mluvíme, ho v jistém smyslu sleduje – jinými slovy ho měří.
Výsledky měření tedy lze popsat jako kanály, jak jsem právě popsal. Ale nejde jen o možnost – jde o
charakterizaci obecných měření. Mám tím na mysli toto: samozřejmě existují kanály,
které nepředstavují měření, protože výstup nemusí být vždy diagonální matice hustoty. Ale pokud
výstup kanálu je vždy diagonální matice hustoty bez ohledu na vstupní stav ρ, pak je nutně možné
vyjádřit tento kanál ve tvaru zobrazeném na obrazovce pro nějakou volbu měření – tedy kolekci
pozitivně semidefinitních matic se součtem rovným identitě. To je pěkné z více důvodů, mimo jiné proto, že nám
v podstatě říká, že naše definice měření jako kolekcí matic nic
neopomíjí. Jiný způsob, jak to říct, je, že tento pohled na měření jako kanály je operační
nebo axiomatický v tom smyslu, že zachycuje, čím měření má být – tedy fyzický proces, který
transformuje kvantovou informaci na klasickou. Ukáže se, že je to zcela ekvivalentní prvnímu
popisu měření, který je čistě algebraický. Důkaz ekvivalence v tomto videu nebudu ukazovat, ale
není obtížný – pokud tě to zajímá, najdeš ho v písemném materiálu k lekci, který je odkazován v popisu videa.
Probrali jsme, co se stane, když je provedeno obecné měření na systému v daném stavu –
alespoň pro případ destruktivních měření. Dále budeme mluvit o parciálních měřeních, tedy o situaci, kdy je
měřena pouze jedna část složeného systému. Konkrétně předpokládejme, že máme dvojici systémů XZ, které
jsou dohromady v stavu popsaném maticí hustoty ρ, a provádíme měření popsané kolekcí pozitivně semidefinitních matic se součtem rovným
identitě pouze na systému X. Přirozeně to vede k
výsledku měření a protože mluvíme o destruktivních měřeních, můžeme si představit, že proces měření systém
X zničí. Stále ale máme systém Z a musíme pochopit, jak měření X ovlivní
stav Z. Nejdříve si proberme pravděpodobnosti
výsledků. Protože mluvíme o měření systému X samotného, pravděpodobnosti různých
výsledků mohou záviset pouze na stavu X v izolaci – tedy pouze na
redukovaném stavu X. Konkrétně pravděpodobnost daného výsledku a je dána
stejným vzorcem jako dříve – stopa PA krát redukovaný stav X, který označujeme ρ
se spodním indexem X. Stav ρX dostaneme z ρ parciální stopou přes Z. Takže tuto
substituci provedeme a – i když to nemusí být hned zřejmé – výraz, který dostaneme, lze alternativně zapsat tak,
jak je ukázáno na obrazovce: jde o stopu PA tensorovaného s maticí identity na systému Z krát
ρ. To je rovnost, která rozhodně stojí za to si ověřit. Intuitivně to dává smysl – se Z nic neděláme,
takže dává smysl, aby se identita na Z takto objevila. Lze to také ověřit
algebraicky a nechám to na tobě s návrhem, abys nejdříve uvážil případ, kdy ρ je tensorový součin dvou matic, a pak
použil linearitu k závěru, že to musí fungovat pro všechna ρ. Dodám také, že to nezávisí na tom, zda PA
je pozitivně semidefinitní nebo zda ρ je matice hustoty – jde o rovnost, která by fungovala pro libovolnou volbu
matic místo PA a ρ, pokud mají správné rozměry pro to, aby výraz
dával smysl. A teď se podívejme, jak měření ovlivní stav Z. Přirozený přístup –
podle mého názoru – je uvažovat o měření jako o kanálu. Zde je kanál, který spojujeme s naším měřením, a
přemýšlíme o něm jako o kanálu ze systému X do nového systému Y, jehož klasické stavy odpovídají výsledkům měření. V tomto vzorci
σ reprezentuje stav systému X samotného. Pokud tento kanál aplikujeme na
systém X, zatímco dvojice XZ je v stavu ρ, dostaneme matici hustoty, kterou máme tady. Opět
si vezmi tolik času, kolik potřebuješ, abys to ověřil, a opět mám návrh, abys nejdřív uvážil případ, kdy ρ je tensorový
součin dvou matic, a pak použil linearitu. Tento typ stavu,
kde první systém je klasický a druhý kvantový, jsme viděli jako příklad v lekci o maticích
hustoty. Každé a se vyskytuje s určitou pravděpodobností – ta je rovna stopě druhého tensorového faktoru – takže si lze tyto
druhé tensorové faktory představit jako matice hustoty vynásobené pravděpodobnostmi. Abychom tedy dostali stav
Z podmíněný na konkrétní výsledek měření a, jednoduše vydělíme pravděpodobností – jinými slovy
normalizujeme druhý tensorový faktor dělením jeho vlastní stopou. Takže shrnuto: pokud provedeme
měření na X, zatímco dvojice XZ je v stavu ρ, stane se toto: za prvé, každý výsledek a se objeví
s pravděpodobností rovnou stopě PA tensorovaného s identitou krát ρ. Za druhé, podmíněno na obdržení
konkrétního výsledku měření a je stav Z dán výrazem zobrazeným na obrazovce – to je to, co dostaneme
normalizací matice, kterou jsme viděli před chvílí. A to je totéž jako dělení matice pravděpodobností,
že se a objeví. Musím zmínit, že to dává smysl pouze tehdy, když je pravděpodobnost nenulová – jinak bychom dělili
nulou. Ale to je v pořádku, protože se nemusíme starat o věci, které se nestávají. V této části
lekce probereme jednoduchý, ale základní teorém o měřeních – Neimarkův
teorém. Stručně řečeno říká, že libovolné měření lze implementovat tak, jak naznačuje obrázek na obrazovce.
Slovy: dané obecné měření na systému X lze implementovat takto –
nejdříve zavedeme inicializovaný pomocný systém Y, jehož klasické stavy jsou možné výsledky měření (předpokládáme, že jsou
číslovány 0 až n minus jedna), poté je provedena unitární operace U na dvojici
YX a poté je provedeno měření standardní báze na Y. Vše je tedy v zásadě dáno
s výjimkou volby U. A teorém říká, že je skutečně možné tuto unitární
operaci U zvolit tak, aby pravděpodobnosti různých výsledků vždy odpovídaly danému obecnému
měření. Nyní se podívejme, jak je Neimarkův teorém dokazován – a není to obtížné. Stačí jen zvolit dobrou hodnotu pro
unitární operaci U a ověřit, že funguje. Nejprve ale potřebujeme základní fakt
z maticové teorie: pro každou pozitivně semidefinitní matici P existuje vždy jedinečná pozitivně semidefinitní
matice Q taková, že Q na druhou je rovno P. Obecně může existovat mnoho matic, jejichž čtverec je P, ale
vždy existuje právě jedna, která je pozitivně semidefinitní. Tuto matici označujeme jako odmocninu
P a tak ji také nazýváme. Pokud chceš odmocninu P pro nějakou pozitivně semidefinitní
matici P vypočítat, můžeš to udělat tak, že nejdříve vypočítáš spektrální rozklad P a pak
každou vlastní hodnotu nahradíš její odmocninou a vlastní vektory ponecháš beze změny. Vlastní hodnoty jsou všechny nezáporné,
takže to dává smysl, a je poměrně snadné vidět, že matice, kterou dostaneme, je skutečně pozitivně semidefinitní
a jejím čtvercem je P. Že je jedinečná, je jiná věc – není obtížné to dokázat
s pomocí základních faktů o maticích, ale je to trochu vedlejší k lekci a tuto část
prostě vezmeme jako danost. Teď, když máme tento koncept, je poměrně snadné specifikovat
unitární operaci U, která funguje. Libovolná unitární matice, která odpovídá vzoru zobrazenému na obrazovce, bude fungovat. Prvních n sloupců –
za předpokladu, že X má n klasických stavů jako dříve – se získá naskládáním odmocnin
matic popisujících měření na sebe, a zbývající sloupce mohou být jakékoli –
nezáleží na tom, pokud je celá matice unitární.
Mimochodem, pokud zaznamenáváš podobnost s propojením Kraussovy a Stinespringsovy reprezentace kanálů – to není náhoda.
Ve skutečnosti to, co zde máme, je v podstatě speciální případ toho, kde naše Kraussovy matice jsou všechny pozitivně
semidefinitní. Jsou tedy dvě věci, které je třeba ověřit. Za prvé, že tato volba U skutečně funguje, a
za druhé, že je možné zvolit nespecifikované sloupce tak, aby U bylo unitární. Začněme tím prvním.
Zde je stav, se kterým začínáme. Spodní systém Y je inicializován do stavu nula, zatímco horní systém
začíná v stavu ρ. Poté provedeme U, což znamená, že konjugujeme
pomocí U. To vše lze zapsat pomocí blokových matic, jak je ukázáno na obrazovce – máme U vlevo, U dagger vpravo
a |0⟩⟨0| tensorované s ρ uprostřed, což má tvar, který tady vidíme: ρ v levém horním rohu
a nuly všude jinde. A pokud se nad tímto součinem zamyslíš, je zřejmé, že
nespecifikované položky U vůbec nezáleží – jsou vždy násobeny nulovými položkami této
matice uprostřed. Pokud vypočteme součin, dostaneme tuto
matici zobrazenou tady, popsanou jako bloková matice. Alternativně ji lze vyjádřit pomocí Diracova zápisu
takto – a to je pro nás pohodlnější. Soustřeďme se tedy na tento
výraz a pro pohodlnost dejme této matici – která je maticí hustoty – název
σ. Posledním krokem je měření standardní báze na Y. Vypočítejme tedy redukovaný stav na Y –
to je snadné s výrazem, který máme. Jednoduše provedeme parciální stopu přes X, což odpovídá druhému tensorovému
faktoru. Pravděpodobnost daného výsledku a je tedy diagonální položka odpovídající a. Lze to zapsat
takto a rovná se to stopě odmocniny PA krát ρ krát odmocniny
PA. Pomocí cyklické vlastnosti stopy dostaneme stopu PA krát ρ,
což je to, co jsme doufali. Pravděpodobnosti různých výsledků jsou tedy správné – vždy odpovídají
původnímu měření, se kterým jsme začali. Druhou věcí, kterou je třeba ověřit,
je, že je možné doplnit nespecifikované sloupce U takovým způsobem, aby se
stala unitární. To plyne z faktu, že prvních n sloupců – které jsou tvořeny odmocninami matic popisujících
měření – jsou ortonormální. To lze poměrně přímočaře ověřit. Příslušné detaily jsou zde
na obrazovce – zastav video a chvíli o tom přemýšlej, pokud chceš. Ale jak jsem naznačil dříve,
jde ve skutečnosti o speciální případ něčeho, s čím jsme se setkali v předchozí lekci. A tím je
důkaz hotov. Dosud jsme se soustředili na destruktivní měření – tedy bez specifikace
postmeasurementového kvantového stavu měřeného systému. U nedestruktivního měření naopak existuje
nejen klasický výsledek měření, ale také postmeasurementový kvantový stav měřeného systému.
Jak uvidíme, existuje přirozená spojitost s Neimarkovým teorémem. Ve skutečnosti existují různé způsoby, jak formulovat nedestruktivní
měření matematicky, ale začneme formulací, která přímo vyplývá z Neimarkova
teorému. Uvažujme obecné měření – destruktivní – popsané kolekcí pozitivně semidefinitních
matic P 0 až PN minus jedna se součtem rovným identitě. Toto
měření lze proměnit v nedestruktivní měření jednoduše tím, že zvážíme implementaci tohoto měření, o které jsme mluvili v kontextu Neimarkova
teorému. Zavedeme nový systém Y, interagujeme ho s X prostřednictvím unitární operace U a poté provedeme měření standardní
báze na Y. Systém X stále existuje a můžeme uvažovat jeho
stav. Na základě analýzy, kterou jsme provedli, můžeme určit, že postmeasurementový stav X podmíněný
na obdržení konkrétního výsledku měření a je dán maticí hustoty, která vypadá
takto: konjugujeme odmocninou odpovídající matice měření a poté
normalizujeme. Jiný způsob, jak formulovat nedestruktivní měření – a to obecnější – je pomocí Kraussových
matic kanálů. Tuto definici měření najdeš například v dobře známé učebnici Nielsena a
Changa. Předpokládejme, že M0 až Mm minus jedna jsou čtvercové matice, které splňují
rovnici zobrazenou na obrazovce – to jest, mohli bychom o těchto maticích přemýšlet jako o Kraussových maticích popisujících
kanál. Ve skutečnosti tyto matice popisují kanál, ale také popisují nedestruktivní měření.
Funguje to tak: když je systém v daném stavu ρ měřen, za prvé jsou pravděpodobnosti výsledků
dány rovnicí zobrazenou na obrazovce. Každý výsledek se objeví s pravděpodobností rovnou stopě Ma krát
ρ krát Ma dagger. A podmíněno na výsledku a stav měřeného
systému vypadá takto. Nedestruktivní měření tohoto druhu lze implementovat
podobně jako to, co jsme měli pro Neimarkův teorém, a nechám to na tobě k zamyšlení, pokud
chceš. Je možné zobecnit pojem nedestruktivního měření ještě dál. Existuje například
pojem tzv. kvantového instrumentu, který je někdy velmi užitečný, ale v tomto
videu se jím nebudu zabývat. V poslední části lekce krátce probereme dvě úlohy spojené s měřeními: diskriminaci kvantových stavů a kvantovou
tomografii stavů. O obou konceptech by se dalo říct mnoho a my je vlastně jen
povrchně nakousneme. Začněme ujasněním, co tyto pojmy znamenají a čím se liší.
Za prvé je to diskriminace kvantových stavů. Myšlenka spočívá v tom, že máme známou kolekci kvantových
stavů nějakého systému spolu s pravděpodobnostmi spojenými s těmito stavy. Přesněji: předpokládejme,
že ρ0 až ρM minus jedna jsou matice hustoty reprezentující možné kvantové stavy systému X, a p0
až pN minus jedna jsou pravděpodobnosti spojené s těmito stavy. Pokud pravděpodobnosti shromáždíme do jednoho
vektoru, dostaneme vektor pravděpodobností. Výstižný způsob, jak to říct, je, že máme soubor kvantových
stavů. Abstraktní způsob, jak přemýšlet o diskriminaci kvantových stavů jako o úloze nebo problému,
je tento: nejdříve je náhodně vybráno číslo od nuly do N minus jedna podle daných pravděpodobností. Systém X je poté
připraven v stavu odpovídajícím náhodně vybranému číslu a cílem je určit pomocí
měření X, které číslo bylo vybráno. Máme tedy konečný počet
alternativ spolu s a priori pravděpodobností a cílem je zjistit, která alternativa skutečně nastala. Pro některé volby stavů a
pravděpodobností to může být snadné a pro jiné nemusí být možné to udělat bez určité šance chyby.
Existují různé konkrétní otázky, které bychom mohli klást – například jaká je minimální pravděpodobnost chyby
a jak vypadá měření, které tuto minimální pravděpodobnost chyby dosahuje. Kvantová tomografie stavů naproti tomu
funguje jinak. Zde máme neznámý kvantový stav systému – obvykle tedy není žádná a priori pravděpodobnost ani informace o
možných alternativách. Tentokrát ale není k dispozici jedna kopie stavu, nýbrž mnoho nezávislých kopií – to jest pro nějaké
možná velké číslo n máme n identických systémů X1 až Xn, z nichž každý je nezávisle připraven v stavu
ρ. Cílem je tentokrát najít aproximaci tohoto neznámého kvantového stavu jako matice hustoty pomocí měření
těchto systémů. Shrnuto: v diskriminaci kvantových stavů máme jednu kopii
stavu a snažíme se rozlišit mezi konečným počtem známých alternativ. V kvantové tomografii stavů máme mnoho nezávislých
kopií neznámého kvantového stavu a cílem je najít jeho popis nebo alespoň dobrou aproximaci.
Diskriminace kvantových stavů je zajímavá, protože abstrahuje typ situace, která se běžně vyskytuje
ve výpočtech a kryptografii – například tam, kde nastala jedna z konečného počtu možností a my (nebo někdo jiný) se
snažíme zjistit, která to byla, měřením kvantového systému. Nejjednodušší netriviální případ je
ten, kdy existují jen dvě alternativy – tedy m je rovno dvěma. Úlohou je tedy rozlišit mezi
dvěma stavy. Tento případ je ve skutečnosti v zásadě zcela vyřešeným problémem, pokud je cílem minimalizovat
pravděpodobnost nesprávné diskriminace. Existuje optimální volba měření a ta se nazývá
Helstromovo měření. Ve skutečnosti jde o projektivní měření a lze ho popsat
takto: nejdříve uvážíme váženou diferenci mezi dvěma alternativami – tedy p0 krát ρ0 minus p1 krát ρ1.
Násobíme tedy pravděpodobnost výběru každého z těchto dvou stavů s daným stavem a
bereme rozdíl. To je hermitovská matice, protože se rovná svému vlastnímu konjugátu transponátu, takže má spektrální
rozklad a víme zejména, že vlastní hodnoty jsou všechna reálná čísla. Předpokládejme tedy, že máme spektrální
rozklad ve tvaru zobrazeném na obrazovce. Dalším krokem je shromáždění vlastních
hodnot do dvou množin, kde všechny kladné jsou v jedné množině a všechny záporné v druhé.
Přesněji: označme S0 jako množinu všech indexů k, pro které je příslušná vlastní hodnota λk
nezáporná, a S1 jako zbývající indexy, odpovídající záporným vlastním
hodnotám. Ve skutečnosti nezáleží na tom, do které množiny zahrneme indexy odpovídající nulovým vlastním hodnotám – zde
arbitrárně volíme, aby byly zahrnuty v S0, ale nebyl by žádný rozdíl, pokud by byly některé nebo všechny zahrnuty v S1. Záleží jen
na tom, abychom oddělili kladné a záporné vlastní hodnoty. A nakonec definujeme dvě projekce Pi
0 a Pi 1, jak je ukázáno na obrazovce. Slovy: Pi 0 je projekce na
podprostor rozepnutý vlastními vektory odpovídajícími nezáporným vlastním hodnotám a Pi 1 je projekce na prostor
rozepnutý vlastními vektory odpovídajícími záporným vlastním hodnotám. Jde skutečně o projekce a
pokud je sečteme, dostaneme matici identity, protože vlastní vektory S0 až SN minus jedna tvoří
ortonormální bázi. Pokud je toto měření provedeno v dané situaci – tedy stav
je ρ0 s pravděpodobností p0 a ρ1 s pravděpodobností p1 – pak se ukáže, že
pravděpodobnost správné identifikace má poměrně jednoduchý vzorec z hlediska vlastních hodnot λ0 až λN minus
jedna. Detaily výpočtu v tomto videu procházet nebudu – pokud tě to zajímá, podívej se do psaného obsahu odkazovaného v popisu videa,
nebo se zkus přesvědčit sám, že tento vzorec je skutečně správný. Tuto
pravděpodobnost lze také vyjádřit pomocí maticové normy, běžně nazývané trasová norma. Notation je podobná eukleidovské normě pro vektory,
jen se spodním indexem 1 označujícím, že jde o trasovou normu. Trasová norma je velmi důležitá a ve
kvantových výpočtech se velmi běžně vyskytuje, ale v této lekci o ní více říkat nebudu. Jeden způsob, jak ji
definovat pro hermitovské matice, je, že je to součet absolutních hodnot vlastních hodnot. Tak si lze tuto druhou rovnost
snadno zdůvodnit přímo z této definice. Trasová norma lze také
definovat jinými, obecnějšími způsoby a znovu se s ní setkáme v příští lekci. Toto je ve skutečnosti
to nejlepší, co lze udělat – toto měření je optimální za předpokladu, že cílem je maximalizovat šanci správného
odhadu. Tento fakt se někdy nazývá Helstrom-Holevo teorém a jindy prostě
Helstromův teorém. Toto měření tedy nelze překonat z hlediska pravděpodobnosti správnosti, a je to pěkné, protože
existuje jednoduchý recept pro samotné měření a přesný vzorec pro pravděpodobnost správnosti z hlediska trasové
normy. Trasová norma se często používá jako způsob měření pozorovatelného rozdílu mezi maticemi hustoty –
přesně z tohoto důvodu. A když lidé mluví o trasové vzdálenosti mezi stavy, obvykle mají na mysli
jednu polovinu trasové normy rozdílu dvou matic hustoty. To zde odpovídá případu, kdy p0 a p1 jsou oba 1/2,
což je přirozený případ. Diskriminace kvantových stavů pro dva stavy je optimálně řešena
Helstromovým měřením, pro které máme jednoduchý recept a jednoduchý vzorec pro pravděpodobnost
správnosti. Co se tedy stane, když chceme rozlišit tři nebo více stavů? V tomto případě obecně nemáme
vzorec pro optimální volbu měření ani jednoduchý výraz pro maximální pravděpodobnost
správnosti. Pomocí počítače je však možné najít dobrou aproximaci optimálního měření –
a to lze udělat pomocí fascinující a výkonné optimalizační techniky zvané semidefinitní programování. Ale to není
něco, co bys mohl realizovat tužkou a papírem. Na druhou stranu, pokud ti někdo dá popis měření a tvrdí,
že toto měření je optimální pro úlohu diskriminace kvantových stavů, je pak vlastně
velmi snadné toto tvrzení buď ověřit, nebo vyvrátit. A to lze udělat pomocí tzv. Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Laxových podmínek. V tomto videu nevysvětlím, co jsou, ale jsou to jednoduché podmínky a je docela skvělé,
že je to možné. Zde je příklad, který se váže k tetrahedrálním stavům,
které jsme viděli dříve v lekci. Předpokládejme, že nám je dán jeden z těchto čtyř stavů vybraný náhodně
s pravděpodobností jedna čtvrtina pro každý, a naším cílem je určit, který stav nám byl dán. Možná to není překvapivé, ale
nejlepší volbou měření k tomuto účelu je tetrahedrální měření. Takto to vždy nefunguje
pro libovolnou kolekci čistých stavů, ale díky symetriím, které jsou zde přítomny, to
funguje a dostaneme platné měření. A prostřednictvím Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Laxových podmínek, které jsem zmínil
před chvílí, se ukáže, že je poměrně snadné dokázat, že toto je skutečně optimální volba
měření. Konkrétně se zde stane, že měření je vždy správné s pravděpodobností 1/2 – což není
špatné, protože existují čtyři alternativy. Pravděpodobnost správného odhadu je tedy dvakrát lepší než náhodné hádání.
A to je to nejlepší, co pro tyto stavy lze udělat. Teď řeknu ještě trochu o kvantové tomografii stavů,
kde máme mnoho nezávislých kopií neznámého kvantového stavu a cílem je najít aproximaci matice hustoty, která
tento stav popisuje. Existuje ve skutečnosti několik různých variant tohoto problému, které závisí na tvých předpokladech – zejména na
tom, jaká měření povolíš. Mohli bychom například požadovat, aby byl každý systém měřen individuálně a výsledky
kombinovány, aby vznikl popis matice hustoty. Nebo bychom mohli dovolit, aby všechny systémy
byly měřeny dohromady jako jeden složený systém, což je v teorii mnohem lepší, ale z technologického
hlediska mnohem náročnější. Vedle volby měření je tu
také důležitá otázka, jak rekonstruovat popis matice hustoty z dat, která z měření získáš.
Nebudu zacházet do detailů – jen chci naznačit,
že kvantová tomografie stavů je spíše zastřešujícím konceptem s mnoha různými variantami než
jedním konkrétním postupem. Tomuto problému bylo věnováno velké množství výzkumu, včetně poměrně
nedávných průlomových výsledků, které propojují počet kopií n s přesností dosažitelné aproximace, a je to i nadále
zajímavá a aktivní oblast výzkumu. Na závěr lekce se podíváme na kvantovou tomografii stavů
pro qubity a na to, jak ji provést. Předpokládejme tedy, že ρ je matice hustoty reprezentující stav
jednoho qubitu a X1 až Xn jsou qubity, které byly všechny nezávisle připraveny v stavu ρ. Pro
účely tohoto výkladu předpokládejme, že n je velké. Co můžeme udělat, je rozdělit
systémy do tří přibližně stejně velkých skupin. Pro první skupinu provedeme měření vzhledem k bázi plus-
mínus. Pro každý výsledek odpovídající plus budeme skórovat plus jedna a pro každý
výsledek odpovídající mínus budeme skórovat mínus jedna. Výstižnější způsob popisu tohoto měření
je, že jde o Pauliho X měření, protože stavy plus a mínus jsou vlastní vektory Pauliho X matice a odpovídající
vlastní hodnoty jsou plus jedna a mínus jedna. A to je vlastně i mnohem běžnější způsob, jak to popisovat.
Očekávaná hodnota skóre je rovna stopě σx krát ρ. Tuto očekávanou hodnotu sice přímo nezjistíme, ale pokud zprůměrujeme skóre,
která získáme přes mnoho a mnoho pokusů, je docela pravděpodobné, že dostaneme
slušnou aproximaci této očekávané hodnoty – díky zákonu velkých čísel. A existují dobře známé statistické odhady, které na to
lze použít, pokud chceme být kvantitativnější. Podobně postupujeme se σy pro druhou třetinu
systémů. Jediná změna je, že používáme stavy |+i⟩ a |-i⟩, které jsou vlastními vektory σy.
A podobně pro σz, pro které jsou vlastními vektory standardní bázové vektory.
A nakonec můžeme použít vzorec zobrazený na obrazovce, který nám říká, jaké by měly být koeficienty,
pokud je ρ zapsáno jako lineární kombinace Pauliho matic. Dosazením naše aproximace pro tyto koeficienty
a případnou jejich úpravou, aby výsledná matice byla pozitivně semidefinitní, dostaneme aproximaci
ρ. Samozřejmě existují detaily, které jsem nerozvedl – například přesnost aproximace a míra
důvěry, kterou v ní můžeme mít. Snad ti to ale dá základní představu o jednom způsobu, jak lze tomografii provést na
qubitu. Je také možné provést qubitovou tomografii pomocí tetrahedrálního měření, a to se ukáže být
poměrně jednoduché a elegantní, alespoň z matematického hlediska. Co můžeme udělat, je provést jen
toto jediné měření na všech nezávislých kopiích našeho neznámého kvantového stavu a pomocí
pozoruhodného vzorce zobrazeného tady přijít s aproximací našeho stavu odhadem stopy PK krát
ρ pro každé K podílem výskytů příslušného výsledku měření. Opět toto funguje jen díky
dokonalým symetriím, které máme mezi těmito čtyřmi stavy. Existují velmi fascinující nevyřešené problémy, které se vztahují ke zobecněním
tohoto přístupu na větší systémy. A to je dobré místo, kde lekci zakončit. Děkuji za sledování a
doufám, že se ke mně přidáš v příští lekci, která pojednává o purifikacích a věrnosti. Na shledanou.